what would you lovely people like to
hear a rap about IIIi heard the second
way was party I miss her the first word
what was it as in Donna meet so if this
sounds like an in-joke that everyone is
aware of so you'll need to explain so to
me Donna is a type of lamb kebab meat
right okay so would you care to explain
a party that was stranded and ate each
other okay where where did this happen
where a lot of people of people have
opinions that this man of his at Sierra
Nevada okay and why were they stranded
plane crash Oh in the old time okay cool
cool it's a regional American history by
the way that is a very good suggestion
if you want to catch a British person
out just you know usually people go with
something like Lou Gehrig or some kind
of sports person I'd never have heard of
but know the Donner Party who were
apparently some gold miners who were
trapped and then decided to eat I mean I
guess not decided like we're probably
forced to it probably was like a well
that's been about an hour without any
contact let's eat Kevin that's right
Donna party that is a great suggestion I
like it very much let's come to this you
guys over here were to a rapper there's
a hand up there yeah SEPA like guys with
beards very imaginative based on the
person that you sat right next to
also quite mean based on the lack of any
hair on my chin and I haven't shaved for
two and a half weeks so guys with beards
what let's kind of just push that a bit
further is there anything particularly
what is it about guys with bids they
they ride into tundra okay
guys into bids ride in it and they they
have trucks okay cool nice nice I love
that you just mind a truck by going I
mean really that's the mind for vehicle
isn't here right that's truck right guys
were bids they have trucks the Donner
Party let's come to the middle front of
the room which will repel one one second
I didn't quite hear it I will come to
you but this lady very politely put hand
up
volleyball okay let's pick a specific
thing about volleyball though because I
don't take the same position twice and
three weeks ago in Australia a
nine-year-old girl said volleyball so I
can't take that it's that suggestion but
what I can do is get you to kind of
expand on it competition in volleyball I
like it that is a good suggestion you
shared something out what was it you
said sign out cider
you've just you saying side out doesn't
mean anything to me oh it's a volleyball
term okay cool
we can we can put it into that side how
rubbish term that is right I think I've
got a lot of people on board they're
like yeah we should rename it
okay so competition volleyball and a
side out guys with beards and their
trucks the Donner Party we need two more
suggestions I'll come to the back yeah
you've got your hands up there
transformational journey into the hybrid
cloud you and one person is super happy
about that
I am not even going to attempt to ask
you to explain that because I'm not sure
anyone here knows what any of that means
let's get one final one from anywhere
this has to be really good though a guy
in a dumpster behind the Vatican do you
know something we don't have you sent
have you sent a contract killer to
Vatican City too dark a cool those are
some great suggestions I mean mainly you
did the heavy lifting and you start us
off really well in the middle we
definitely sagged a little bit so to
remind you all the Donner Party guys
with beards and the fat they drive
trucks competition in volleyball maybe
including sideout a transformational
journey into the hybrid cloud and yes
I'm quite impressed I remembered that
and a guy in a dumpster behind the
Vatican this then lovely people of the
comedy magic club little treat for you
guys a little thing called a freestyle
rap that as a rap made upon the spot
based on telling those suggestions do
not worry it will not be anywhere near
as atrociously embarassingly toe-curling
ly bad as you were expecting a privately
educated middle class white boy to be
hey friends is me wearing the same
clothes but with slightly longer hair
because time passes I just launched a
challenge where I want to see you guys
rap there are details on screen right
now but also a link to a video that
explains it more fully I cannot wait to
see what you guys come up with now back
to the video let's drop that Pete my
friend and have some fun
[Music]
and turnout for me as well I've got your
real nice West Coast be it's gonna be
great I'm you lad the chief on bass nice
kick it off yeah don't know what I'm
talkin about
let me serve let me spike let me get a
side out what the heck is that now the
balls no longer in play but when it's on
the volleyball put our whole sway I'm
the best when it comes to scoring those
points if you come enough to meet my
dislocate roids I break your arm I break
your shoulder and your hip
cuz when I'm playing competition yeah I
never sleep I get so angry and get the
red rise up I'm gonna make sure that I
slice I'm gonna [ __ ] you down with my
father ball skills competition followed
oh yeah it gives me thrill do some
people say you should play it through
the amateur way I'm like now I'm a pro
y'all should go away you went out on the
beach go inside you can see me even
though I'm a guy I'm rockin the bikini
you showing everybody and then I go
who's next I get a little hungry so I'm
in need of doing a whole mouthful of
human protein I'm gonna chow down I'm
Jeffrey Dahmer you would put them in the
fridge back in the day I spit about it
the Donner Party down in the gold
crystal have a good time and then
suddenly who has the transport oh no in
position we are caught we eat first look
at the sleeves this guy's quite skinny
and this guy Steve was really fat so
definitely the first to go we get him
down Oh Steve
sorry break it down in his belly
he's not aware because we killed him
first yeah we did it really good hug him
upside down to drain the meat off the
blood you don't want all the stress
proteins to end in the blood out of his
whole bloodstream it's not nice to make
light of here people but when you're in
the desert yes all equal out in Sierra
Nevada I know I'd rather eat
slightly overweight when I take anybody
on a dinner date I see come in it's got
plus ones allowed gonna have a
transformational journey into the hybrid
cloud the freeway is so amazing when you
see this seems really know I explore
myself in having so much fun I know in
America different words you plop though
you wouldn't call that skip you would
call it a dumpster look in there
I say me oh my oh there comes a very
stinky long-haired guy this is some kind
of joke no I'm Ratzenberger's he old
coke I was kicked out to Campanas
because the new one came along and he
said I'm very managers towards you and
so you go down with all the recycling
hoho kicked me out of the spire out of
the coupler that's a real architectural
reference there if you feed that's no
joke they pick a new pub a white and the
black smoke if I can see it's very small
but very brief you see a guy in the
doctor probably smell [ __ ] you stay away
from him because he ponds a bit maybe
he's a guy and if you bear that you
would spit it out again it wouldn't
taste very fresh last one yeah it's easy
to guess why you said beer
cuz to your left a guy you sat there and
he does select and never shave just bro
his facial hair what car does he drive a
Tundra
apparently is not car you can look it up
it's a brand new Toyota bad things a
truck that you can ride it along like
this not this
you get bristle bird on your face when
you kiss and that is one thing that I
have always feared they even when I'm 60
I'll never grow a bit
[Applause]